ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาตี
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเจอกับกลัวตี้ครูพี่เอ๋
ในช่องคอม frenzel ไทยโอเค
ครูเอ็ดดี้ขา
วันนี้
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ The นะคิดคอร์ดก็
วันนี้นี่เอาปฏิทินมาแล้วครับวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ครับ
วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่สามทับวัน
นี้ ok เพื่อนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือน
มิถุนายนครับเดือนมิถุนายนเดือนที่ 6 นะ
คะๆครับเดือนมิถุนายนปี
คศอะไรคะหน้าปีคศ 2000  22
ค่ะแล้วปีพศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ครับ
2565 ได้อร่อย 625
555 ครับโอเคสวัสดีค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่
โมงตอนนี้ 20:00 นควรที่ไม่เขียนเลข 2
แล้วคราวนี้เขาได้เขียนเลข 8 อ่ะ
โอ้โหทุ่ม 45 ครับผมอ่า 2 ทุ่ม 45 นาที PM
เดี๋ยวนะ
ฮัลโหลทำไมแข็ง
โฟเซ่นล่ะคะโอเคอ่ามาไหมครับ
8:45 นครับค่ะ 2 ทุ่ม 45 นาทีนะคะแล้วก็
คลิปนี้เหมือนเดิมค่ะครูปาร์ตี้กับครูเอก
เจอกันหาว่าจะพานักเรียนไปไปเที่ยวอีก
แล้วนะวันนี้ไอวันนี้ไปเที่ยวที่ไหนครับ
วันนี้ก็เมื่อวานครู Arty พาไปบุรีรัมย์
บุรีรัมย์บ้านน้องริต้าใช่ไหมบ้านน้องลี
ซานอีสาน
หน้ากูเอกกลมแบบนี้ก็สวัสดีเจ้าเอ่อ
มีคนเมืองคนเมืองกับเจ้า
เจ้า
นักเรียนบอกอะไรพูดอะไรเป็นภาษาไทยนะภาษา
ไทยแต่ว่าคนที่อยู่ภาคเหนือ
แบบนั้นประมาณปวดที่พูดไม่เหมือนนะแต่
ประมาณนั้น
เขาบอกว่าหน้ากูเองเหมือนคนภาคเหนือแต่
กรูเหนะพูดภาคเหนือไม่ได้คนภาคเหนือพูด
พูดเวลาฟังน่ะโว้ยเพราะหน้าใจครับพี่เค้า
ก็จะพูดสวัสดีเจ้าโทษนะคะถ้าผิดถ้าครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้ครูเอ๋เลยครับอาจจะพูดชัด
หนา
นุ่มๆเอ็นๆนะครับสบายสบายสวยๆนะคะเดี๋ยว
กู a  Share  screen นิดนึง
ราคาอ่ะ
ตัวลุคอะนะตรงนี้ก่อนนะครับอ่ะคุยไม่
แผนที่นะคะแผนที่ประเทศไทยกว่าที่มองเห็น
ไหมค่ะมองเห็นครับมองเห็นนะคะได้ครับ
สักครู่นะคะที่นี้เนี่ยอ่ะครูมีแผนที่นี่
แล้วก็ตัวเองขยายขยายมานิติวัฒน์เอง
ที่นี่ First โอเคครับก็เป็นภาคเหนือราคา
ภาคเหนือตรงนี้นักเรียนวันนี้จะพาไปภาค
เหนือภาคเหนือจังหวัดอะไรดีครับวันนี้
อยู่ดังวัดใช่ไหมสีเขียวภาคเหนือโอเค
เราจะไปจังหวัดนี้กันค่ะครู Arty จังหวัด
ที่มี
โค้งของเยอะที่สุดในประเทศไทยคงเยอะที่
สุด 1,000
245 ไหมคุณถ้าจำไม่ได้และ
ลดแล้วนะคะเหมือนกับแค่นี้จริงนะ 3,000
คงเอา
1,200 นั้นจังหวัดตากว่ะไม่รู้ครับคือ
รู้จำไม่ได้ไม่หลายทีกว่าติอันนั้นที่นี่
ก็มีตรงนี้อ่า
แต่แต่ตอนนี้โค้งอาจจะน้อยลงแล้วก็ได้ค่ะ
เพราะว่าเขาเขาตัดโค้งทิ้งหอจะได้ถึงเร็ว
ๆใช่ไหมให้คือนักเรียนช้าจังหวัดเนี้ย
ชื่อว่าจังหวัดอะไรคะครู Arty ถ้ามีโค้ง
เยอะๆเนี่ยกลัวตีนึกถึงนึกถึงจังหวัดนี้
ครับ
แม่ฮ่องสอนครับถ้า
จังหวัดแม่ฮ่องสอน
คือคือนักเรียนเนี่ยสามารถไปแม่ฮ่องสอน
ได้โดยการนั่งเครื่องบินนะหัว Arty ให้
กับนั่งเครื่องบินไปได้ไม่ต้องขับรถไม่
ต้องจะผ่านโค้งเยอะๆใช่สถานโค้งเยอะๆก็
สนุกดีนะ
เครื่องบินจากกรุงเทพฯเนาะ
กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ไปเชียงใหม่
แล้วก็จากเชียงใหม่ไปแม่ฮ่องสอนเขานะคะ
คือต้องเปลี่ยนเครื่องนะคะเปลี่ยนไม่มี
ไม่มีจากกรุงเทพไปแม่ฮ่องสอนไม่มีมีไหมมี
ไหมเมื่อก่อนไม่มีอ่ะตอนนี้พิมพ์ตอนนี้ก็
ปวดพูดไม่รู้งานก๋วยตีปกติกวนตีไปแมวใส่
ก็ตีขับรถไปรถไปที่่ก็นั่งรถไปค่ะ
กูเอกอูอาตี้กูอีกนั่งรถไฟ
นั่งรถไฟไปแม่ฮ่องสอนไรครับใช่ๆควรที่มอง
เห็นไหมคะให้เนี่ยเห็นรถไฟรถไฟ
จากกรุงเทพฯเชียงใหม่นี้นะคะอ้าเนี่ยไป
เชียงใหม่ขับก็จากเชียงใหม่ก็นั่งรถ
รถตู้ขอ
ขวดตีคิดว่ากูเห็นนั่งรถไฟไปจังหวัด
แม่ฮ่องสอน
อ๋อโอเคไม่ไม่มีรถไฟไปแม่ฮ่องสอนใช่กับ
ผัวแต่คิดว่าไม่มีรถไฟเลยไม่ออกตอนพ่อรถ
ไฟขึ้นภูเขา
ลำบากเครื่องภูเขาไม่ได้
เขาสิว
รถจากเชียงใหม่ไปแม่ฮ่องสอนก็ต้องเป็นรส
สั้นๆลดรดยาวๆก็ตื่นเต้นน่ากลัวนะคะ
เนื่องจากอะไรเพราะว่าแม่ฮ่องสอนจะมีภู
เขาเยอะนักเรียนให้ครับมีผู้เก็บสีแดงออก
ว่าอา
ร์โฟล์คก่อนครับอ่ะ
ก็ภูเขาภูเขาภูเขา
เราจะไปแล้วก็ต้องอ้อมภูเขาใช่ไหมคะเอา
นี่เป็นถนนมีถนนอ้อมภูเขาอ้อม
นักเรียนแบบเนี้ย
นานเลยครับกว่าจะถึงขับรถนานเลยโค๊ดที่
บอกว่าครู Arty เคยขับรถไปห้องสอนขับใช่
ไหมคะครูอาร์ทตี้ขับรถจาก
กรุงเทพรู้จักเชียงใหม่
ขับจากเชียงใหม่ครับอ๋อไปเชียงใหม่ยังไง
คะก็ขับรถจากกรุงเทพฯไปเชียงใหม่
แสดงว่าขับรถจากกรุงกรุงเทพไปเชียงใหม่
ก็ไปนอนที่เชียงใหม่ก่อนแต่ครับแล้วก็อต
ตี้ก็ขับรถจากเชียงใหม่ถ่ายสอนใช่
ไม่เหนื่อยเหรอคะ 5 ก็สนุกดีครับครัวนี่
ก็ไปแวะไปแวะดอยอินทนนท์จะไปแวะ
แม่ฮ่องสอนไปปางอุ๋งไปหลายๆที่ครับขอ 5
ไปแวะที่นี่ภูเขาแวะไปเรื่อยๆครับไม่ได้
ขับทีไม่ได้ขับวันเดียวไปแม่ฮ่องสอนเลย
แล้วขับคนเดียวหรือว่า 2 คนขับคนเดียว
ครับเก่งคนเดียวคือทะกรุงเทพฯเชียงใหม่
เชียงใหม่กรุงเทพฯนะโอเคนะแต่กรุงเทพ
เชียงใหม่เชียงใหม่เข้าแม่ฮ่องสอน
แม่ฮ่องสอนมาเชียงใหม่แล้วเชียงใหม่
มากรุงเทพฯ 5
ไปกะใหญ่บางทีก็ไปเชียงใหม่เชียงรายไป
แม่ฮ่องสอนไปปายไปไปด้วยกับไปหลายๆทีจะไป
อีกแล้วไว้ใช้เวลาหลายๆวันอ่ะอาจจะไปค่า
วันไปหลายๆจังหวัดเราก็ใจที่วันนี้น่าจะ
เล่าให้ฟังว่าครูเอ๋นะคะนักเรียนอยากจะไป
เที่ยวแม่ฮ่องสอนน้ำเงิน
และขอ
ขอบคุณเพื่อนๆแต่ว่าอันนี้คือปลามาประมาณ
กลัวตี้เรื่องนี้ประมาณ 25 ปีที่แล้วนะคะ
อ๋อโอ้ 25 ปีที่แล้ว K  25 ปีที่แล้วหน้า
ไม่เหมือนกันแล้วพ่อไม่เหมือนกับต้นไม้โต
ขึ้นแล้วใช่ไหมครับเมื่อก่อนต้นไม้เล็กๆ
เดี๋ยวนี้ต้นไม้ต้นใหญ่แล้ว
อะไรไม่ใช่อย่างนี้ตอนนั้นน่ะก็ไปกันคืน
นั่งรถไฟไปแล้วไปเชียงใหม่เราก็คิดจะไป
แม่ฮ่องสอนแต่ครูคะไปครั้งที่ 2
ครั้งอ่ะครั้งที่ 1 ก็นั่งรถรถบัสกรุงเทพ
เชียงใหม่แล้วก็เปลี่ยนเป็นรถตู้กรุงเทพ-
แม่ฮ่องสอนก็เลยรู้ว่าอ้อถนนมีโค้งอ้ะ
โอ๊ะนั่งรถเหนื่อยนะเหนื่อยและหยาบ
เหนื่อยแล้วก็จะเวียนหัวอ้าวเวียนหัวพอรถ
เลี้ยวไปเลี้ยวเที่ยวไปเดี๋ยวมาก็เวียน
หัวใจได้ก็ถามครูปาร์ตี้ว่าครูอาร์ตี้ขับ
รถแล้วรถมันเดี๋ยวเลี้ยวซ้ายเดี๋ยวเลี้ยว
ขวาขายป่าขึ้นลงอย่างเงี้ย
กับทางโค้งเนี่ยกู Arty เวียนหัวไหมคะ
ควยตี้โชคดีที่ครัวติไม่เวียนหัวหน้าไม่
มีผัวแล้วลูกๆเวียนหัวไหมคะอ่าไม่เวียน
หัวเหมือนกันไม่มีไปเวียนหัวโชคดีดีมากนะ
คะดีว่าฮ่าๆๆเพราะว่าครั้งแรกที่ครูเอไป
อ้ะรถรถทั้งหมดประมาณ 10 คันนะรถตู้เนี่ย
ลิง 10 คันโก้คนเยอะเลยใช่ไหมครับไปหลาย
คนไปเยอะค่ะกูเอกไปทำงานครั้งที่ 1 หรือ
จะเอาคนไทยไปเที่ยวนะคะไปเที่ยวแล้วกูเอง
ก็เห็นเห็นคนอ่ะจอดรถแล้วก็
ๆทำอะไรครับการเจียวเรียนเพราะว่ากลัวที่
คิดว่าเขาอาเจียนตอนนัดรถเรียกว่าเรียก
ว่าเมารถใช่ไหมครับให้เบารถเมารถเวลาที่
รถเลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวขวาขึ้นตั้งบนลงข้าง
ล่างเลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวขวานะข้อสอบนะคะอ่ะ
คะอันนี้คือรถรถเนี่ยขึ้นมาข้างบนแล้วก็
ที่นี่ก็หักศอกแบบนี้ไปเป็นทางโค้งหักศอก
ใช่ไหมใช้เขาปุ่มกลับมาแบบเนี้ยนะถ้า
อย่างนี้ก็ลงมาแบบนี้นักเรียนสอบวันนี้
อ้าเลี้ยวทำให้คนนั่งเนี่ยเวียนหัวนะคะ
อ่ะนะคะนักเรียนไม่เข้าใจเวียนหัวนะคะกู
Arty ติให้เป็นไงขึ้นนะคะดีขึ้นแล้วยืน
แล้วก็หมุน
ฮ่าๆ
ๆหมุนหลายๆรอบนะหมุน 5 รอบก็ได้หกรอบก็
ได้อย่ามูลเยอะฝุ่นเยอะเดี๋ยวเวียนหัวมาก
ครูเอกของหมุนรอบเดียวนะ
ห้าก็คือก็เป็นการก็เลยเรียกว่าเวียนหัว
ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่น้องไปเลี้ยวมาเลี้ยวไป
เลี้ยวมา
สนุกใช่ไหมอาหารสนุกได้แล้วตอนนั้นตอน
นั้นที่กูแอบไปเป็นยังไงครับพี่ทิพย์แรก
เนี่ยคุยไปทำงานแบบที่ 2 ไปกับเพื่อนที่
นั่งรถไฟแล้วคือเอกก็จะเคยไปแล้วก็จะรู้
ใช่ไหมเพื่อนน่ะเขาอยากไปไปอันนี้อ่ะอ่ะ
เขาอยากจะไปคุยมีรูปให้ดูถ้าอยากไปด่วน
ค่ะค่ะอยากไปดูอ่ะหนึ่งคือภูเขาที่เป็น
ดอกไม้ดอกไม้สีเหลืองโอเควันที่รู้จักมัน
มีชื่อนี่ครับเป็นทุ่งเป็นพุ่งเข้าที่
แล้วเราไปทุ่งทานตะวันจะแม้แต่คราวนี้ที่
นี่ที่ภาคเหนือไม่มีดอกทานตะวันเป็นดอก
ดอกบัวดอกบัวตองอ่า
ก็เราอยากจะไปดู 1 บัวตองอ่า
สองนี้เราอยากจะไปดูห้วยน้ำดัง
ห้วยน้ำดังใจมิการเป็นได้ตั้งใจเลยครู
Arty ตั้งใจว่าจะดูอันนี้ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อจะไป
ดูหมอกหมอกเยอะๆบนภูเขาเรียกว่าทะเล
เหมือนกันว่าทะเลหมอกไงครับไปค่ะแล้วก็ก็
จะดูอันนี้พระอาทิตย์ขึ้นพระอาทิตย์ขึ้น
เคเพื่อนเพื่อนๆอยากดู
เอมบอกว่าเออโอกาสเห็นนิดหน่อยนะเพื่อน
ต้องตื่นแต่เช้าไปนั่งรอนั่งรอพระอาทิตย์
มาหรือยังประเทศหาผู้ a ไปตั้งแต่ 05:00
นอ๋อก็ไม่เห็นอ้าวพระอาทิตย์ไม่มาล่ะครับ
กูไอ้ไปตั้งอ่ะตี 5 นักเรียนตีห้าสีแดงดี
กว่าเนาะ
สีอะไรมองเห็นอ้ะสีขาว 5:00 น 5:00 ครับ
ตี 5 นะคะรอจนถึง 10:00 น
10:00 นตี้คิดว่าพระอาทิตย์ไปตั้งนาน
แล้วครับ
ไม่เห็นพระอาทิตย์ครู Arty อ๋อไอ้ครั้ง
ที่ 1 นะไม่เห็นนะคะทำไมไม่เห็นครับพระ
อาทิตย์อยู่นะครับอาทิตย์ไม่หยุดแต่ว่ามี
เมฆอ๋อ
เมฆเมฆเมฆเยอะเมฆบางไว้พระอาทิตย์อยู่
หลังแม่กูเอกก็เลยมองไม่เห็นไม่เห็นไม่
เห็นมาทิศอยู่ไหนไม่เห็นอ้อที่สวยๆเห็นตอ
นร้อนๆ
ที่นี้เนี่ยเพื่อนครูเอ๋ก็บอกว่าต้องเห็น
อยากไปอยากไปก็นี้ค่ะเรามีแผนที่
เชียงใหม่นะคะเจ้าสอน
คืนนั้นน่ะครูเอ๋กับเพื่อนๆผัวตี้ครับนอน
กันน่ะ
ตีประมาณตี 1  01:30 นขอนอนดึกใช่ไป
เที่ยวไงไปเชียงใหม่เนี่ยเราก็ประมาณ
ประมาณ 01:30 นไป
จะนอนแล้วโชเฟอร์คนขับรถนะครับอ่าคนขับรถ
ก็บอกว่าตี 3 นะประมาณ 03:00 น 03:00 น
ถึง 3:30 น
เตรียมตัวใช่ไหม
อะขึ้นรถ
ที่มะปี 3 นะครับปีสามขึ้นอ่ะทุกคนขึ้นรถ
เพื่อที่จะไปปืนตรงนี้
หน้าไปดูทะเลหมอกไหมครับได้ไปดูทะเลหมอก
3:30 น
นอนตอน 01:00 น 1:00 นแล้วก็ตี 2 ตี 3
คืนอ้อน้อย 1 ชั่วโมงคือครึ่งเองไม่โอเค
นะ 1 ชั่วโมงครึ่ง 2 ชั่วโมงมาเนี้ยกล่าว
คือต้องเก็บเสื้อผ้าใส่กระเป๋าไว้ค่ะนอน
ตื่นขึ้นมาไม่ต้องอาบน้ำล้างไม่ออก
อา
กูเอบอกมาโชเฟอร์
โมงเช้าก็ได้
8 โมงเช้ากูอีกคิดนะ 8:00 นไม่ต้อง 3:30
นสโอเวอร์บอกว่าไม่ได้ไม่ได้ให้คนเมารถหา
3:30 นแล้วนอนที่รถอ๋ออ่อนอนในรถนะโอเค
มาถึงที่นี่ก็จะโอ๊ะเห็นพระอาทิตย์คนไว้
เก็บผ้าทิพย์มาขึ้นมาพอดี
เขาบอกว่าเขาบอกนะอ่าเขาบอกแบบนั้นน่ะ
แล้วกูเอกก็ไปนอนเถอะไม่บอกไม่เห็นหรอก
แต่ทุกคนไม่ฟังกูเองไอตัวเองบอกไม่เห็น
หรอก 8:00 นเถอะนอนนานๆแต่ทุกคนบอกไม่เอา
จะรู้ดู OK ได้ครับดีขึ้นรถ 3:00 นกับก็
ไปคู่เอกก็มีมีมีมีของแจกเพื่อนๆมีอะไรมา
แจกครับมีอันนี้ค่ะเดี๋ยวกูเอง
ซื้อเป็นซองแบบนี้
แล้วก็ข้างในเป็นเม็ดเล็กๆสีแบบนี้แหละสี
แบบนี้
ไม่เอาบอกเห็นในเม็ดอ้ะสีส้มอ่อนๆโอเคอัน
นี้เห็นชัดแล้วครับเม็ดเล็กๆ
เอกมีเพื่อนทั้งหมดไปอ่ะสิบคนใช่มั้ยกู
อีกอะอ้ะมัน 1 เมตรเมตรใช่ไหมครับได้
ขึ้นอะไรออกกินแล้วไม่เมารถอ๋ออ๋ออ๋อจะ
ได้ไม่เวียนหัวหน้าไม่เมารถโอเคกับบางคน
ก็ไม่กินน่ะๆเป็นไรวันนี้เมาหลอกไม่ต้อง
กินโอเคคนก็ไม่กินน่ะเอาเองกินเถอะแล้ว
นอน
นักเรียนคนขับรถนะคือถ้าใครกินแล้วก็หลับ
เนี่ยโอเคแต่กูเอกก็ไม่กินนะอ้าวๆเอาคู่
เอกเคยไปแล้วใช่ไหมถ่ายชายรถก็เหวี่ยง
อ้าว
คนที่ไม่กินเวียนหัวเมาเครื่องคนที่กินยา
เป็นยานะคะยาแก้วเมาน่ะหลับแล้วก็ไม่รู้
ตื่นขึ้นมาเนี่ยถึงแล้ว R ไม่เมาๆถึงที่
ที่นี่ค่ะกูอะตี้ห้วยน้ำดังกว่าที่เคยไป
น้องเคยไปครับโอ้วทุกคนก็คิดโอ้ยจะดูพระ
อาทิตย์หน้าพระอาทิตย์มาหรือยังมาถึงแล้ว
ไม่มีพระอาทิตย์ค่ะอ่ะกินข้าวไปถึงเนี่ย
เป็นแบบนี้ค่ะกว่าสิ
จะคุยอันนี้ให้ป้านี่เป็นแบบนี้เลยค่ะ
มืดยังมืดอยู่ใน up
มืดที่สุด 05:00 นอ๋อเคก็ต้องนั่งรอ
เดี๋ยวพระอาทิตย์ก็ขึ้นรอรอ
นิดนึงโอเคเราจนถึง 6:00 นรอไม่ออกเหรอ 1
6 โมง 6 โมงเริ่มสว่างนิดหน่อยไหมสว่าง
หรือยังมืดก็ยังเมื่อคืนเหมือนเดิมทำไม
มืดทำไมมืด 18:00 นแล้วไม่รู้วันนั้นมีมี
แม่กับครู Arty เมฆเยอะมาก
คู๋แน่นอนที่รถเก๋
อ่าคู๋นะนอนนอนที่รถเพื่อนกูเองเนี่ยออก
ไปรอหนอ
รอพระอาทิตย์มาหรือยังมาหรือยัง
ไม่มาหรือยัง
รอรอจนถึง
08:00 น
08:00 ครัวตี้คิดว่าพระอาทิตย์หน้าจะ
ขึ้นไปไกลแล้วครับและในดัดตรงนี้ไปละ
โอเค 08:00 นเป็นแบบนี้ครับครู Arty
ประมาณแปดเก้าโมงหมอครับไม่ไม่ไม่เห็นพระ
อาทิตย์แล้วแม่ทุกคนน่ะทุกคนนะผมเนี่ยมี
น้ำน้ำ
เราก็หนาว
แล้วทุกคนก็โกรธตัวเองอ้าวไม่ลงจากรถ
อ้าวลองทำไมอ่ะอ่ะกูเห็นรู้อยู่แล้วว่า
ไม่เห็นด้วยได้แน่นอนดีกว่าได้ค่ะถี่คือ
ห้วยน้ำดังนั้นนักเรียนคะสวยมากนะคะสวย
แต่โอกาสที่เราจะเห็นพระอาทิตย์แบบเนี้ย
ราคาเห็นพระอาทิตย์ขึ้นนิดหน่อยเนาะกลับ
ไม่เยอะไม่เยอะน้อยมากใช่ไหมครับว่าเมฆ
เยอะนะคะใช่เห็นในโชคดีนะคะว่าตีก็ไม่เคย
เห็นใช่ไหมไม่เคย
and ปะติดต้องไปนอนอยู่นั้นนักฆ่าวัน
ผัวอ้าวอ้าวอันหาจะได้เห็นนะคะพี่ไปดูที่
อื่นก็ได้ไปดูที่ดอยอินทนนท์ก็ได้เออไปดู
ที่ปางอุ๋งก็ได้นะที่แม่ฮ่องสอนมีปลาหู
ต้องดูที่นี่
จริงๆอื่นทุกวันได้ครับมีหลายๆที่ค่ะแต่
แต่ว่าตอนนั้นคืนอยากจะมาอยู่ที่นี่มากเค
กอล์ฟไม่ดูดไม่ได้เห็นนะคะทุกคนก็ภาษาไทย
ปกค่ะอ่าโอเคไม่ลงนะคะเพราะว่าเราจะไปวัด
แวะพักที่ปายบริเวณนี้เรียกว่าห้วยน้ำดัง
เค้าจะใกล้กับปลาย
เราก็ไปไปที่ปลายค่ะที่ปลายก็เป็นอำเภอ
อำเภอที่อยู่ในจังหวัดแม่ฮ่องสอนหน้าได้
เอกให้ดูแผนที่ก่อนดีกว่าเนาะเดี๋ยวนัก
เรียนจะได้ไปที่ปลายโอเคจากที่นี่หมาย
ครับอยู่ตรงใหม่ 2 ใช่ไหมนานเมื่อกี้กู
เองวงหมายเลข 2 ที่เป็นอุทยานแห่งชาติ
ห้วยน้ำดังเอาไว้
ไปอีกนิดนึงก็ถึงปายแล้วให้ปิดการนะคะก็
ไปเป็นปลายควรตีใช่ไหมต่อมก่อนนะไปแบบไม่
ได้ไม่ได้จองที่พักก็ขับรถเพื่อนคนหนึ่ง
บอกว่าอันนี้ตื่นเต้นดีขับรถไปแล้วก็หา
ที่ปลาไม่ต้องจองไปหาเอากินเค้าไม่มีแหละ
ปกติคิดว่าถ้าเมืองก่อนน่าจะมีน่าจะหา
ง่ายแต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ต้องจอง
ตอนนี้ไม่จองไม่ได้นะคะนักเรียนต้อง
โทรศัพท์ก็จะไป 5 คนขอห้องนอน 3 ห้องยัง
ไงต้องจองนะคะที่นี้ก็จะมีเวลาเนาะก็คือ
พอพอไปปั๊บเนี่ยไม่ได้จองแล้วก็ขับไปแล้ว
ก็มีหนังสือมีหนังสือเที่ยวประเทศไทย
หนังสือเกี่ยวกับสถานที่ท่องเที่ยวใช่ไหม
ครับในเคหนังสือบอกว่ายังไงบอกว่ามี
รีสอร์ทดีมาก
คนอเมริกาชอบคนยุโรปชอบคนถ้าชอบขอมีรี
สอร์ทสวยๆใช่ไหมไม่รู้สึกจะชื่อปางไอ้ปาย
คันทรี่ฮัทอ้อปลายคันที่หัดแล้วครูเอกก็
ไปที่นี่ใช่ไหมครับไปกันเลยอ่าพอเข้าไป
ปลื้มเป็นไงบ้างโชเฟอร์เรียวออกแล้ว
อ้าวทำไมล่ะไม่สวยหรอเดี๋ยวออกทำไมไอ้ตี้
สวยของคนไทยกับสวยของคนต่างชาติไม่ต้องพอ
ขอเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะ
หน้าเป็นกระท่อมหรือเป็นบ้านทรงไทยครับ
กระท่อมค่ะอ๋อ
กับคอมแบบมองเห็นข้างในอ่ะเป็นไม้
แบบนี้
แล้วไม้มาจากต้นไผ่อ่ะค่ะเป็นกระท่อมไม้
ไผ่อ่ะเอ้อใช่แต่ไม้อันเนี้ยคือมองเห็น
ข้างในนะอ๋อที่ชาวเป็นแสดงว่าเป็นอ่า
เหมือนกระท่อมของชาวเขาจะไม่ครับให้แล้ว
แล้วเวลาเดินตื่นเต้นจังเลย
ที่สำคัญคือเวลาปวดท้องเนี่ยตรงนี้ไม่มี
ห้องน้ำอ๋อต้องมาประมาณ 20 เมตร
ไกลเลยแล้วก็ห้องน้ำ
ห้องน้ำ
ครีม
ออก
ไม่นอนไปที่อื่นไปที่อื่นดีกว่าอ่ะแต่นัก
เรียนครับปี 2022
รีสอร์ทนี้ไม่ใช่แบบนี้แล้วค่ะสวยสวยแล้ว
ใช่ไหมครับมีห้องน้ำที่นี่แล้วนะคะมีห้อง
น้ำ
เขาก็เปลี่ยนสวยขึ้นแต่อันนี้ 4  25 ปี
ที่แล้วก็ตื่นเต้นนิดหน่อยนะฮะเราก็
เปลี่ยนแล้วจนหารีสอร์ทได้เป็นได้แบบนี้
มาประมาณนี้ค่ะเข้ามานี่ไปนอนที่อื่นเป็น
อยากนอนกระท่อมไม้ไผ่โอเคก็จะนอนประมาณ
นี้นะคะประมาณรูปนี้เป็นเป็นบ้านทรงใคร
กับเป็นบ้านทรงไทยแล้วเราก็ไปที่นี่นี่
หนู
[เพลง]
น้ำน้ำพุน้ำพุร้อนน้ำพุร้อนอ่ะหัวที่เห็น
มีควันอยู่ด้วยแสดงว่าต้องร้อนแน่ๆ 80
องศาเซลเซียส
80 องศาเซลเซียสร้อนไหมคะต้มไข่ได้เลย
ต้มคนก็ได้
เลยไปนะที่เนี่ยมีบันไดมีบันไดเดินไปวนๆ
เดินไปค่ะมาก็จะมีน้ำพุร้อนเราก็ถ้าเป็น
ตอนนี้นะคะตอนกูเองไปนะไม่มีตอนนี้เขามี
ตัวนี้ด้วยก็สวัสดีมีอะไรครับมีเป็นตัว
นี้มีครูแนนนะคะมีโครนลิโคลนตัวนี้เขาจะ
เอามาทาตัว
R ตัวให้เป็นสีสวยๆนะคะคนตัวนี้จะอยู่ใน
นี้
อยู่ในภูโคนนะคะหมอ
เขาบอกว่าดีมากถ้าครู Arty อะร่างกายไม่
แข็งแรงไม่สบายเอาโคนมาทาขอพาตัวแล้วก็จะ
แข็งแรงแข็งแรง
ต้องถ้าทุกวันไหมครับหรือไปครั้งเดียว
แข็งแรงเลยไปวัดซื้อกลับบ้านออกอธิบายมา
คือคืนจังหวัดแม่ฮ่องสอนอำเภอปายเนี่ยเขา
ตอนนี้มีมีคนไปเที่ยวมากๆมีเยรีสอร์ตเยอะ
ๆแต่ตอนที่กูแอบไปน่ะไม่มีมีพี่
สาวไม่เยอะใช่ไหมครับหน้าแต่ตอนนี้เยอะ
แล้วเพราะคนไปเที่ยวเยอะไอ้นะคะแล้วก็ตอน
นี้สบายๆแต่ถ้าเป็นเมื่อก่อนน่ะยางนิด
หน่อยนะครับเพราะว่าที่สนุกก็คือว่าหัวตี
รู้ไหมอ่ะเราเนี่ยก็ซื้ออาหารคิดว่าเราจะ
บาร์บีคิวครับก็บอกโชเฟอร์ว่าโชเฟอร์
เดี๋ยว 6 โมงนะอ่ะหลังจากเราเราไปไปเล่น
เล่นน้ำร้อน
เล่นเสร็จแล้วก็กลับมาแล้วก็บอกว่าอ่ะ
หลัง 6 โมงมารับเราออกไปกินข้าว
โชเฟอร์ทิ้งเลยอ้าวเฟอร์ใหม่มา
ไม่รู้
น่าจะไปนอน
ที่เขาฮ่าๆจบเอ้อไปหาเพื่อนฮ่าๆรู้่กับ
เพื่อนๆก็เลยต้องบาร์บีคิวกินกันอ๋อ
แบบปลายเป็น 4ps เป็นอำเภอเมืองที่น่าไป
เที่ยวนะคะยังคู่ Arty ไปกว่าตีชอบไหมค่ะ
ชอบครับปาร์ตี้ก็ไปนอนไปนอนที่น่าจะเป็น
รีสอร์ทเหมือนกันอยู่ใกล้ๆกับที่ท่อง
เที่ยวมีทางเดินเป็นตั้งคืนจะมีคณาอาหาร
ขายอาหารข้างทางแบบนี้ชายตลาด 5 เป็นตลาด
บางๆจีนใจเก็บมาเนี่ยเปลี่ยนนะคะนักเรียน
ไปเปลี่ยนสวยมีที่พักดีๆมากๆร้านกาแฟเยอะ
ด้วย
สมัยก่อนไม่มีแล้วตอนนี้มีร้านกาแฟเยอะ
ด้วยอ่าเปิดตีนไปมาประมาณ 2 ปีที่แล้วก็
ไป
ไปหนูน่ะ 25 ปีได้แล้วมั้งฮะโหเปิดมีแม่
30 ปีต้อง 25 ปีที่แล้ว
ก็ได้บอกโอ๊ยแตกยังจำได้แล้วก็ดูคลิปเด็ก
ปวดหายอยากจะไปอีกนะครับ
โอเคค่ะวันนี้ก็หมดหมดเวลาแล้วครับว้าวไป
เที่ยวไปอ่ะไปบอกโคลนไปดูพระอาทิตย์ขึ้น
แถไม่เห็นพระอาทิตย์
หน้าไปใหม่ก็คิดว่าคิดว่าไม่ดูแล้ว
คิดว่าไม่ดูมีคนบอกว่าสวยมากเราก็อยากจะ
เห็นนะคะแต่ไปคิดว่าไม่ดูแล้วค่ะไปไปอะไร
นะไปครอบครัวดีกว่า
นะคะค่ะงั้นคืนนี้ครูเอกกับผัวนี่ก็ไป
ก่อนค่ะโอเคเดี๋ยวกลับมาเจอกันใหม่คราว
หน้าครับวันนี้สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋เอ๋สวัสดี
ค่ะเบี้ยนไวท์บายโอ
ม.ค